[Música]
Donald Trump insistió en que hubo fraude
electoral en las elecciones de 2020 en
Estados Unidos el expresidente contestó
formalmente al comité que Investiga el
asalto al Capitolio y que ayer decidió
citarlo a declarar sin que Trump muestra
intención de cumplir con la citación
Haití se enfrenta a una catástrofe
humanitaria por la violencia en las
calles la escasez de alimentos y un
nuevo brote de cólera así lo confirma el
nuevo informe del programa mundial de
alimentos de las Naciones Unidas
y continúa el aumento de precios en
Argentina la inflación se sitúa en el
6,2% de septiembre en el país
suramericano esto deja la inflación
interanual en el 83% afectando
especialmente a los combustibles y los
alimentos
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo
dedicado a las principales noticias del
continente americano Soy Rodrigo sedano
y es un gusto acompañarlos abrimos esta
emisión en Estados Unidos el
expresidente Donald Trump respondió por
carta a la comisión de investigación de
la cámara de representantes que votó de
forma unánime citarlo para esclarecer
los hechos del asalto al Capitolio del 6
de enero de 2021 Trump volvió a insistir
en un fraude electoral sin aportar
pruebas el informe final sobre el asalto
se hará público a finales de año Aunque
parece poco probable que Trump vaya a
declarar tiene más detalles lluis Muñoz
señor presidente en esta votación hay
nueve por el Sí y cero por el no se
acuerda la resolución unánime Donald
Trump tendrá que comparecer ante la
cámara de representantes la comisión que
Investiga el asalto al Capitolio del 6
de enero de 2021 acusó el ex presidente
de tener un plan premeditado para
declararse ganador de las elecciones
aunque perdiese
él es la única persona en el centro de
la historia de lo que sucedió el 6 de
enero
debe responder ante millones de
estadounidenses cuyos votos quería
desechar como parte de su esquema para
permanecer en el poder
parece poco probable que el comité pueda
interrogar al expresidente Trump puede
recurrir la citación y en última
instancia negarse a contestar a las
preguntas si habló en su propia
plataforma 3 social
Por qué no me pidió la comisión no
seleccionada que testificara hace meses
porque esperaron hasta el final los
últimos momentos de su reunión porque la
comisión es una basura Total que solo ha
servido para dividir aún más a nuestro
país que por cierto va muy mal unas
Hazme reír en todo el mundo la comisión
argumentó que Trump sabía que había
perdido querían usar el hecho de que los
demócratas votan más por correo para
frenar el conteo en ese contexto se
conoció una declaración inédita de
Victoria electoral también llamados a la
violencia de asesores de Trump y nuevos
vídeos de los sucesos del 6 de enero
cuando partidarios de Trump
interrumpieron en la sede del congreso
para evitar que se certificase El
Triunfo de Joe biden según el más
reciente informe del programa mundial de
alimentos saetí se enfrenta una
catástrofe humanitaria debido a la
violencia en las calles que ha
ocasionado que cientos de personas
sufran escasez de alimentos y agua
potable además un nuevo brote de cólera
pone en riesgo a la población Andrés
granadillo tiene los detalles
Haití al borde de una catástrofe
humanitaria Es la advertencia que lanza
este viernes el programa mundial de
alimentos de Naciones Unidas
la situación de la seguridad alimentaria
en Haití está empeorando el informe dice
que según las cifras que tenemos 4,7
millones de personas en Haití se
enfrentan a una inseguridad alimentaria
aguda de las cuales 1,8 millones se
enfrentan a niveles de emergencia de
inseguridad alimentaria
unas 19.000 personas en cité solé uno de
los barrios más pobres de Puerto
Príncipe se enfrentan a un hambre
catastrófica debido al aumento de la
violencia además unos 100.000 niños
menores de 5 años en Haití sufren de
desnutrición severa
Hace seis meses teníamos cifras más
bajas estamos viendo un aumento de
200.000 personas en situación de
inseguridad alimentaria aguda y un
aumento de medio millón de personas para
los niveles de emergencia
Hay personas clasificadas en la fase 5
Esta es la peor clasificación en la
escala de 5 puntos que actualizamos para
calificar la inseguridad alimentaria
Y es que hace un mes las bandas
haditianas impiden la distribución de
gasóleo y gasolina lo que paraliza a
negocios y hospitales sectores de Puerto
Príncipe están literalmente aislados por
las mafias que con barricadas impiden
que la capital se comunique con otras
ciudades del país la situación crea
escasez de productos básicos y vitales
como el agua y la gente lucha para poder
llegar a sus trabajos hace menos de una
semana el Primer Ministro Gabriel Ángel
propuso que fuerzas internacionales
ayudaran para luchar contra la
inseguridad el secretario general de la
ONU Antonio Gutiérrez pidió el
despliegue inmediato de una Fuerza
Armada especial sumado a esto el país
más pobre de América Latina se enfrenta
a un brote de cólera que hasta el
momento ha dejado 18 muertos y 32 casos
confirmados
seguimos en América Latina en Argentina
los precios continúan en aumentos según
informó el Instituto Nacional de
estadística y censos en el mes de
septiembre la inflación fue del 6,2%.
una pequeña desaceleración respecto a la
cifra de agosto pese a ello la inflación
interanual alcanzó el 83%. lo que supone
el mayor incremento desde 1991
anteriormente Gustavo nefa economista de
la Universidad Nacional de la plata en
Argentina nos contaba Cómo afecta esta
situación a los ciudadanos
Bueno hay una encuesta de Focus que
habla de un 10% de caída en el consumo
sí de las tiendas o almacenes los
argentinos están remodelando sus
consumos para
intentar ahorrar más y obviamente que el
incremento de precio golpea El poder
adquisitivo del bolsillo de los
trabajadores por quinto año consecutivo
es una erosión del Poder adquisitivo del
poder de compra de los argentinos por
quinto año consecutivo Que obviamente se
sufre en el día a día la pobreza es
mucho más alta como como
expectativas y se adelante de la
inflación que se acelere y obviamente de
un desempleo que incluye la cifra
oficial todos aquellos planes sociales
que Obviamente que sin ellos estaría muy
por encima del 11% actualmente
ligeramente por bajo el 7
y en Perú saltó una nueva polémica que
salpica importantes figuras del estado y
es que la fiscal general del país
Patricia Benavides figuró temporalmente
como fallecida en el Registro Nacional
de identificación y estado civil en lo
que el organismo ha denominado como una
manipulación de los registros oficiales
también apareció como fallecido el
ciudadano Alejandro Sánchez buscado por
las autoridades como parte de una
presunta organización criminal en El
Ejecutivo de Pedro Castillo
y este 14 de octubre se conmemora el Día
Mundial del reciclaje de desechos
electrónicos en Ecuador una nueva
normativa obliga a productores y
consumidores a recolectarlos nuestro
corresponsal Gustavo Ortega se trasladó
a un centro de reciclado electrónico en
la ciudad de Guayaquil y nos cuenta la
historia
tengo esto
aprende a reciclar sus desechos
electrónicos como ella cada ecuatoriano
acumula un promedio de 5,3 kilogramos
anuales en un país sin cultura de
reciclado no sabemos dónde desecharlos
Porque si bien es cierto tirar basura
nos perjudica al medio ambiente pues no
y más bien tenemos que colaborar hoy en
día para un mejor mundo oportunidad que
motiva Gustavo Marriott un analista de
sistemas convertido en gestor ambiental
quien intenta concienciar a los
Ecuatorianos con la instalación de
contenedores elaborados de desechos
plásticos y residuos electrónicos para
deshacerse los aparatos tecnológicos en
desuso
todo comienza aquí con 35 toneladas de
residuos tecnológicos casi el 100% puede
ser aprovechada o reinsertada en el
mercado el 95% de lo que nosotros
procesamos es recuperable Es decir desde
el plástico el cobre el aluminio la
chatarra
soy recetados localmente y lo que se
exporta básicamente son las tarjetas
electrónicas a refinerías donde lo que
hacen es fundir el material y recuperar
oro paladio plata en este pequeño centro
de recuperación Wander Nieves técnico
informático fomenta un mercado circular
emergente Ecuador está promoviendo una
normativa que obliga a productores y
empresarios a recuperar los desechos
electrónicos que produce la cadena
productiva para que puedan seguir dando
sus funciones y así apoyando aquellas
personas cuyos recursos son muy bajos
dando los equipos a buen precio
impresoras se fomenta la economía
circular reduciendo de carbono de
productos
de vuelta este centro de recolección
dividen desarman y clasifican la basura
tecnológica
destruye y compactan por en práctica el
eco valor y la responsabilidad extendida
de productos nuevos términos a los que
Gustavo acostumbra a los Ecuatorianos
esto significa 90.000 toneladas al año
de esto solamente entre el 3 y el 5%
reciclado correctamente una minería
urbana que aspira a liberar de su basura
tecnológica en menos de 10 años al
Ecuador
hasta aquí este informativo se han
conectados
[Música]